oh it's self arete again and I have
decided that this amazing little roller
coaster is going to be called okay
please please cooperate we're going
there freiheit
nope not like that
alright and this one will be the
Lancelot and then yeah maiming is done
no idea why I did that on the video but
might as well just because I had those
ideas it's a bit of attack on Titan a
bit of code geass and it's time to move
on so let's start no the time lapse
perfect
you win
one
all right so all that's left for me to
do right here right now it's just some
finishing touches on the rockwork right
here now as you can see I actually use
many sets for the rockwork for example I
use Weber's sets Weber's large rock set
Weber's foliage sets I'm using my girl
peppers using mighty rocks and the
reason why I'm doing this is okay it
really annoys me in roller coaster well
it doesn't annoy well it's not smart in
ronica screen theory to build a huge
mountain of rocks out of the same rock
the same texture maybe not the same
shape but same texture and it still does
make a difference whether whether you've
got multiple kinds of textures or
whether you're using one texture for
example the mistake that I see many
people making with for example is set
like shyguys rocks is they'll use many
different shapes of rocks but just one
texture and it'll look like one big wall
of unrealistic boring bland rock without
real depth to it and you can create some
feel of feeling of depth using more
rocks and it's just a little bit of
variation and it makes the entire
mountain or whatever you're making
that's boring like I did with the flying
coaster over here actually use many sets
now another thing that I have learned
just through some experience is that
Rock work does look better if you
scatter it out in clusters but also if
you surround these clusters by smaller
rocks like for example some rocks will
break off or something and they'll turn
into somewhat smaller stones they'll
just lie down somewhere just like these
small rocks that I got over here these
mossy ones and I don't know it just
creates kind of a fading blending idea
between a hard rocky place and the
grassy plains next to it so that's also
a tip I would like to give people to do
but yeah then I'm basically finished
I've done everything that I wanted to do
and for this coaster so all that's left
for me to do is foliage but I'll do that
in the later stage so now I can work on
something else and I'll do that next
episode
so see you then